did you ever hang out with George Kittle
here I know he lives here you know his
sister
um taught me yoga for a while Emma
Kettle really yeah do you like yoga I do
like it man I do like it sometimes I
just want I wish four people would just
pull off just completely pull my body
apart and run away with them
because I feel like almost once the four
forces combined it's just a bad deal
your sister taught me yoga yeah I know
that's what she was like yeah I'm
teaching Theo Von yoga and I was like
really that's awesome good for you so
cool man was that here yeah yeah right
here she taught me yoga because I think
you guys didn't live very far away we
literally live a block away yeah I sold
that we live out like west of Nashville
now but yeah we lived there for two
years yeah so it's a pretty easy uh uh
commute she's the best man she was like
very
she's like very like Mo like kind of
like ladylike and motherly but like very
like scent like a Sensei kind of she's
she she Vibes dude yes she's got a great
vibe to her yes like a Vibe Surfer or
something like you know she's like the
female Laird Hamilton of Vibes I feel
like that's a Savage compliment man yeah
and she um dude she had me do this thing
one time it was like wearing these
things but between my toes right yeah
and it's like you Yoga Toes or I mean
it's just like this thing you wear at
night it's almost like a spacers yes or
what color were they blue or what uh
well I tried the freaking blue ones dude
the blue ones dude I'm obsessed with
those the blues I see you could probably
do but can you pull up those toe spacers
oh yeah dude I uh she got me into those
right so they're awesome whenever I take
my Netflix this Netflix special that I
did
um she had been teaching right so if you
see me walk I'm walking out like this
because she taught me how to walk like a
Paleolithic yeah no I know exactly what
you're talking about dude we talking
about that stuff all the time when your
sister was helping me do yoga and I just
bring that back because we would talk
about you sometimes and
um and she was always really interested
in like the next like staying on the
pulse of like
one thing that was interesting was she's
like she helps train you guys do yoga
and stuff she's always like but she's
like yeah we stay on the try just try to
stay on The Cutting Edge she's just gone
to a conference I think about
I think it was some type of new yoga or
something I can't remember what it's
called but yeah but it was just
interesting she's like yeah our family's
big into this I was a pretty good kid I
didn't really do a lot like I was very
nice I played football basketball and
then I came home and I played Halo 3.
that's about all I did oh dang it's
pretty easy I was low-key where are you
yes very my sister wasn't but you know
what you can have her on the podcast to
discuss that yeah maybe sometime that'd
be interesting I didn't fight my sister
she beat the out of me sometimes
that was about it but like I didn't
really have an opportunity to fire
because she was she was like 5 10 at the
age of 10 just whooped up on wow was she
dude she was like she was a stallion
back in the day like she's like when she
played high school basketball like she
could fight me and beat me up pretty
easily damn so like I was like yeah what
do you need some of that footage I think
if she didn't only fans of just that you
want to see my my 17 year old sister's
highlights I'd watch a 17 year old girl
beat up George Kittle yeah for nine
dollars a month yeah George Kittle yeah
sure you know what honestly it's not
that weird you say it like that yeah
young jerk kid I'm not saying like yeah
next time I see her
um when you look at uh
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one